E
UK ECONOMY.
>> ANNA STEWART LIVE FOR US,
THERE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THE UN SAYS IT'S CALLED
ENDING WORLD POVERTY BY 2030 IS
IN GRAVE DANGER AND THREATENING
THE VERY SURVIVAL OF HUMANITY.
AND THEY WERE MAKING PROGRESS,
DEALING WITH POVERTY, HUNGER,
INEQUALITY, AND MORE.
THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC
OBLITERATED MORE THAN FOUR
YEARS OF GAINS.
NOW WHAT WEALTHIER NATIONS ARE
BOUNCING, BACK A FRIGHTFUL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY
IN THE WORLD'S POOREST
COUNTRIES, ARE PERISHING.
CONFLICT AND CLIMATE CHANGE ARE
MAKING THE PROBLEMS
UNIMAGINABLY WORSE.
ONE OUT OF EVERY TEN PEOPLE
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH FOOD
TO EAT FROM DAY TODAY.
TENS OF MILLIONS, MANY OF WHOSE
WHOLE EXISTENCE DEPENDS ON LAND,
ARE DISPLACED.
THE UN'S 2030 AGENDA FOR
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT AIMS TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THESE ISSUES ON
A GLOBAL SCALE, AND THE LEADERS
MUST RECALIBRATE IF THEY PLAN
TO DRASTICALLY TRANSFORM OUR
WORLD OVER THE NEXT EIGHT
YEARS.
TEN OF THE EXCHANGE, AND
DISCUSSION WITH MELINDA GATES,
A WORLD RENOWNED PHILANTHROPIST
IN GLOBAL ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN
AND GIRLS.
THE GATES FOUNDATION SPENT TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TACKLING
GLOBAL POVERTY AND INEQUALITY
AND JUST THIS MONTH, IT
ANNOUNCED ITS 2020 GOALKEEPERS
REPORT, ADDRESSING THE UN'S
GLOBAL GOALS.
LISTEN TO WHAT MRS. GATES HAD
TO SAY.
>> LINDA, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US, AS WE KNOW OF,
COURSE IN 2015, THE UN LAUNCH
17 VERY AMBITIOUS SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT GOALS, INCLUDING I
THINK THE MOST AMBITIOUS WERE,
ZERO HUNGER FOR EXAMPLE, ENDING
POVERTY BY THE YEAR 2030,
GENDER EQUALITY AS WELL.
BUT THE WORLD HAS OF COURSE
CHANGED SINCE 2015, AND SO HOW
HAS FOR EXAMPLE CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THE PANDEMIC, THE WAR IN
UKRAINE, HOW HAS THAT CHANGE
THE CALCULUS AS TO HOW AND WHEN
WE ACHIEVE THESE GOALS.
>> WELL AS YOU, SAID THESE
GOALS WERE SET IN 2015, AND WE
WERE MAKING, AS A WORLD,
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS ON A
NUMBER OF THEM.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, THE PANDEMIC
AND THE OTHER CRISES THAT YOU
MENTIONED, HAVE REALLY SET US
BACK ON ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
GOAL.
IT IS REALLY QUITE DEVASTATING
TO SEE, AND WE ARE CALLING, AS
A FOUNDATION ON THE WORLD, TO
REALLY INVEST SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS AND
TO CATCH UP, QUITE FRANKLY, I
MEMBER OF THESE GOALS.
>> AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT ONE
GOAL IN PARTICULAR THAT I'M
INTERESTED IN.
I AM FROM NIGERIA, SO I AM FROM
WEST AFRICA, AND SO I FOUND IT
QUITE SURPRISING AND QUITE
DISHEARTENING THAT A WAR IN
EUROPE CAN LEAD TO MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
WORLD, 6000 MILES AWAY IN EAST
AFRICA, BEING ON THE BRINK OF
STARVATION.
WHAT HAS THIS PARTICULAR WAR
TAUGHT US ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF DEVELOPING NATIONS,
ESPECIALLY IN AFRICA, BEING
MUCH MORE SELF SUFFICIENT, AND
NOT RELYING SO HEAVILY ON
IMPORTS TO FEED THEIR OWN
PEOPLE.
>> WELL, WE ARE SEEING HUNGER
PRETTY MUCH ACROSS THE
CONTINENT INCREASING.
IT IS VERY DEVASTATING TO SEE.
IT IS BECAUSE, 14 AFRICAN
COUNTRIES ARE RELIANT ON HALF
OF THE WHEAT PRODUCTION COMING
FROM THAT UKRAINIAN RUSSIAN
REGION.
AND SO I THINK WHAT IT HAS
SHOWN US AS A WORLD IS NOT ONLY
DO WE NEED A COURSE TO GIVE
HUMANITARIAN AID RIGHT NOW FOR
HUNGER, BUT WE HAVE TO INVEST
IN FOOD RATIONS, WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE NEW
DROUGHT RESISTANT SEEDS ARE
FLOOD RESISTANT SEEDS BECAUSE
THE RAIN IS COMING IN DELUGE,
OR THESE --
THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR CERTAIN
REGIONS, THAT THEY GET OUT AND
INTO PEOPLES HANDS WITH THE
RIGHT INFORMATION ON WHEN TO
PLANT, AND WHAT OTHER TOOLS TO
USE ALONG WITH THEM.
AND THOSE SEEDS NEED TO GET OUT
NOT JUST A MALE FARMERS, BUT
HALF OF THE FARMERS ARE FEMALE.
GET IN THE HANDS OF FEMALES AS
WELL, AND THEN THE CONTINENT IN
COUNTRIES CAN FEED THEMSELVES.
>> AS YOU POINT OUT IN THIS
REPORT, HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE
AND FOOD AID FROM DEVELOPED
COUNTRIES TO DEVELOPING
COUNTRIES IS ONLY INCREASING
YEAR ON YEAR.
IT MIGHT BE A STRETCH FOR MY
LIFETIME, BUT WHEN WILL WE SEE
A POINT WHERE THERE WILL BE
ZERO AID, THAT DEVELOPING
COUNTRIES, ESPECIALLY, AFRICA
WILL BE SO SELF SUFFICIENT BUT
ZERO AIDE IS NEEDED.
>> I DON'T THINK WE KNOW WHEN
THAT WILL BE.
I THINK WE WERE ON A PATH TO
GET TO ZERO AID AT SOME POINT
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC HIT.
NONE OF US COULD HAVE PREDICTED
THIS PANDEMIC, AND NOT JUST THE
HEALTH RAMIFICATIONS, BUT THE
UNBELIEVABLE DESTRUCTION OF
LIVELIHOODS AROUND THE WORLD
AND ACROSS THE CONTINENT OF
AFRICA.
AND THAT IS WHY WE ARE SEEING,
WE HAVE TO MAKE INVESTMENTS,
THESE ARE INVESTMENTS THAT YOU
MAKE IN A COUNTRY, INNOVATIONS,
INGENUITY, BECAUSE THEY THEN
LIFT THEMSELVES OUT AND CREATE
THEIR OWN BUSINESSES IN UP TO
THEIR OWN ECONOMIES.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT GENDER
EQUALITY, BECAUSE AS YOU AND I
BOTH, KNOW THE PANDEMIC WAS A
REAL SETBACK FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS
ALL OF THE WORLD BUT ESPECIALLY
IN THE DEVELOPING WORLD.
WOMEN TEND TO HAVE LESS ACCESS
TO SOCIAL PROTECTIONS, WOMEN
ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE FORCED
INTO EARLY MARRIAGES, THAT SORT
OF THING.
AND SO JUST WALK US, THROUGH
THERE'S ONE PARTICULAR LINE IN
THE REPORT THAT REALLY STOOD
OUT TO ME, AND WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS IDEA THAT IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT WOMEN HAVING EMPOWERMENT,
AND, ACTUALLY MORE POWER, WHAT
DID YOU MEAN BY, THAT AND HOW
DO YOU MEASURE THAT.
>> WHAT I MEANT IS THAT WOMEN
NEED TO HAVE ECONOMIC POWER.
WHEN THEY HAVE MONEY IN THEIR
HANDS, AND NOT JUST, CASH BUT
MONEY FOR INSTANCE IN A DIGITAL
WALLET, WHAT WE SAW EVEN DURING
THE PANDEMIC IS THAT WOMEN IN
NIGER, WHEN THEY HAVE A DIGITAL
PAYMENT MADE INTO THEIR WALLET,
THERE WERE 70% MORE LIKELY TO
LEAVE THEIR HOME AND GO TO THE
MIC REPLACE.
THEY WERE 15% MORE LIKELY TO
BUY GREENS.
WHEN YOU MAKE SURE THAT WOMEN
HAVE PROTECTED ASSETS, THEY CAN
BUILD ON THOSE, THEY CAN SPIN
THE RIGHT WAY FOR THEIR
FAMILIES, FOR THEMSELVES, THEY
CAN PUT THEIR DAUGHTER OR SON
IN SCHOOL.
THEY CAN START TO SAY HEY, I
CAN BUILD SOME CREDIT AND
EVENTUALLY HAVE A CREDIT
RATING.
YOU PUT PEOPLE ON A CYCLE OF
ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT, AND WOMEN
IN PARTICULAR, AND WOMEN WILL
TELL YOU ALL ACROSS THE
CONTINENT, WHEN I HAVE ECONOMIC,
MEANS MY SON LOOKS AT ME
DIFFERENTLY.
MY HUSBAND LOOKS AT ME
MY MOTHER-IN-LAW DOES.
THAT IS EMPOWERMENT, AND WE CAN
DO IT, AND THE PHONE GIVES US A
OPPORTUNITY FOR HAVING DIGITAL
WALLETS FOR WOMEN.
>> YOU TALKED A NEW REPORT
ABOUT THIS IDEA THAT GENDER
EQUALITY, WE MIGHT NOT SEE
GENDER EQUALITY IN THIS WORLD,
UNTIL THE YEAR 21 HUNDREDS.
20 108 I THINK IS THE EXACT
YEAR.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
GENDER EQUALITY IS THAT IT IS
QUITE HARD TO MEASURE IT WOULD
BE IT IS ALSO QUITE UNEVEN AND
THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM COUNTRY
TO COUNTRY AND IN SPECIFIC
COUNTRIES WOMEN MIGHT BE
ADVANCING IN ONE PARTICULAR
AREA, BUT GOING THE OPPOSITE
WAY IN ANOTHER AREA.
HOW DO YOU MEASURE GENDER
EQUALITY AND WHAT DO WE NEED TO
SEE OVER THE NEXT 100 YEARS FOR
WOMEN TO ACTUALLY SEE MORE
EQUALITY COMPARED TO MEN.
>> YOU CAN MEASURE GENDER
EQUALITY BUT YOU MEASURE IT
THROUGH A WHOLE HOST OF
FACTORS.
IS A GIRL IN A QUALITY
SECONDARY SCHOOL, DOES SHE
COMPLETE IT?
ARE THERE FEMALE POLITICIANS IN
EQUAL NUMBERS TO MAN IN
PARLIAMENT, IN CONGRESS, AND
ARE THERE WOMEN WHO ARE
INDUSTRY LEADERS IN THE TOP
COMPANIES IN THEIR COUNTRY?
THOSE ARE THREE INDICATORS OUT
OF ABOUT 45 THAT YOU CAN
MEASURE AND ACROSS THE SCALES
YOU CAN LOOK AND SEE WHERE OUR
WOMEN AND WHAT ARE HOLDING THE
BACK COUNTRY AFTER COUNTRY.
WHAT I KNOW IS THAT WHEN YOU
EMPOWER A WOMAN, SHE EMPOWERS
EVERYBODY AROUND HER.
IN HER FAMILY, AND HER
COMMUNITY, IN OUR SOCIETY.
AND SO WE HAVE TO GET WOMEN TO
THE TOP OF FINANCE, WE HAVE TO
GET WOMEN IN MEDIA, WE HAVE TO
GET WOMEN AT THE TOP OF THE
TECH SECTOR BECAUSE THEY ARE
RECREATING THE WORLD.
WE HAVE THE TOP OF POLITICS,
BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE WE CREATE
OUR POLICIES FOR SOCIETY.